an investigation was carried out on four
different plant species to determine
which of three species was most closely
related to an unknown plant species the
results of the investigation are shown
in the data table below which plant
species appears to be most closely
related to the unknown species support
your answer so pause this video and see
if you can figure that out alright so
here in this data the first row is for
our unknown species we know that it
tests positive for enzyme M this is
blanked out because this is says how
many differences in amino acid sequences
are there between the species in that
row and the unknown species and of
course the unknown species would have
zero differences because it is itself
and then this is the gel electrophoresis
banding pattern so what we want to do is
look for as many similarities as
possible to our unknown plant species so
first if we looked at the enzyme whether
we test positive for it species one does
not test positive for its species two
and three do so species one is not
looking good if we look at differences
in amino acid sequences species one once
again has the most differences in amino
acid sequences so that confirms our
belief that it might be the most
different from plant from the unknown
plant species but then if we look
between plant species two and three
plant species two has fewer differences
so right now plant species two is
looking like the leading candidate plant
species three has more differences and
then when we look at the gel
electrophoresis banding pattern plant
species two has the exact same pattern
as our unknown plant it's the only one
with the exact same pattern and so
because of that I'm feeling really good
saying that two is most closely related
to the unknown species two because same
banding pattern banding pattern and we
could say and least different least
different amino acid sequences amino
acid sequences
and test positive for enzyme M tests
positive for enzyme enzyme M let's do
another question like this scientists
attempted to determine the evolutionary
relationships between three different
finch species a B and C in order to do
this they examined the physical
characteristics and DNA of these species
DNA was extracted from all three species
and analyzed using gel electrophoresis
the results are shown in the diagram and
then they asked us which statement best
describes the method used above to
determine the evolutionary relationships
between three species of finches so the
first choice is examine the structure of
the beaks and compare them statement to
observed behavioral and physical
characteristics of all the finches and
group them by similarities C obtained
molecular evidence from all three
species and identify similarities for
compare common ancestors of all three of
the species and see if they are the same
so pause this video and see which choice
you like alright well clearly they're
looking at molecular evidence they're
taking the DNA of the different species
they're amplifying them which means
they're making a bunch of copies of
certain sequences of that DNA and then
they're running a gel which means they
allow those different segments to
separate on this gel the smaller
segments are going to migrate down
further the larger segments are going to
migrate less far and the more
similarities you have on this gel
electrophoresis right over here
this banding pattern the more similarity
the more similar that DNA probably is
and so they are definitely using
molecular evidence and three is the only
one that talks about molecular evidence
so I will go with choice three they did
say in the beginning that they're
looking that they examined physical
characteristics and DNA of these species
and so you could maybe say examine the
structure of the beaks and compare them
but that's very specific and it didn't
say for sure that they're doing that
that that may be one of the physical
characteristics that they're looking at
but we know for sure that they are
obtaining molecular evidence from all
three species and they're identifying
the similarities so now this next part
it says based on the data they collected
using gel electrophoresis label the
branching tree diagram below writing the
letters a B and C to represent the
possible evolutionary relationships
between species a b and c so pause this
video and see if you can figure this out
and I'll look at I'll show you the
banding pattern again alright so down
there and actually I'll redraw it up
here they draw a tree that looks like
this and they want us to put A's B's and
C's in these blanks here and one way to
think about it is these two are more
closely related they have a more a more
recent common ancestor than the then
from this one over here so if we look at
the banding patterns it's pretty clear
we have this similar band on a and B we
have this similar band on a and B and
they have this band right over here in
common although C shares that one as
well
the only other band that a shares in
common with C is this one right over
here
and B doesn't share anything else in
common with C so it's pretty cut it's
pretty clear that a and B share the most
common banding patterns so I would write
that a and B have the most recent common
ancestor and that C is more distant